president Trump slams you Elijah
Cummings and Baltimore Democrats rushed
to declare racism and President Obama
finally at long last chimes in I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well whenever you think it's gonna be a
really slow weekend President Trump he's
bored he's sitting around the White
House watching some Fox and Friends just
didn't join himself maybe eating some
Cheetos whatever it is and then he just
starts tweeting and you know the world
is going to explode and as with nearly
every weekend that's what happened this
weekend so let's just jump right into
the news president Trump decides over
the weekend that he needs to watch Fox
and Friends
now when President Trump watches Fox and
Friends he basically becomes a commenter
on a right-wing website or a caller to
talk radio meaning he just sort of
spouts into the void
it says folks online say Donnie from
Queens called and that's what President
Trump did he was watching a segment on
Fox and Friends about the shortcomings
of Baltimore and in particular he was
very upset at representative Elijah
Cummings who is one of the Congress
people who is now calling for president
Trump's impeachment and this led
President Trump to sound off Doni from
Queens on the air quote representative
Elijah Cummings has been a brutal bully
shouting and screaming at the great men
and women of border patrol about
conditions at the southern border when
actually his Baltimore district is far
worse and more dangerous his strict
restricted the worst in the United
States has proven last week during a
congressional tour the border has clean
efficient and well-run jizz very crowded
humming district is disgusting rat and
rodent infested mess if he spent more
time in Baltimore maybe he could help
clean up is very dangerous and filthy
place and then he concluded along these
lines why is so much money sent to the
Elijah Cummings district when it is
considered the worst run and most
dangerous anywhere in the United States
no human being would want to live there
where is all this money going
how much is stolen investigate this
corrupt mess immediately hey so the
media immediately jumped all over this
how could President Trump label Elijah
Cummings a bad Congress person how could
president Trump rip into Baltimore as a
terrible terrible place so they
immediately labeled this racist a couple
of things first off when president from
tweets this kind of stuff it's not
helpful the reason that it's not helpful
generally is not because he's not
putting his focus in the right places
because he doesn't actually care I mean
President Trump is not coming up with an
inner city policy for Baltimore
then sing listen Baltimore has been a
failing mess for decades on end
here is my plan why won't Democrats work
with me to improve Baltimore
instead it's Elijah Cummings is a jerk
and he city's terrible his city's
garbage and you know that's what
President Trump is doing because he has
now done this with Wanda and he's done
this with New York City
he's done this with New Hampshire he
does this over and over whenever he sees
a politician he doesn't like he
immediately goes to that person's area
is bad right their district is basicity
John Lewis a few years ago he does this
on a fairly regular basis so is that
useful to the American public discourse
no it's not
but we're president Trump's tweets
useful to the American public discourse
I think that we would already know that
by now president from tweets come in a
few different shades one is useful where
is sort of informing you about the
economy or where he is saying that
certain things are unacceptable in terms
of foreign policy and then there's
things that are useful but overwrought
right certain things where he goes over
the point but what he's saying is
actually kind of true then there is
useless but true okay that one is this
one and then there is just bad it's bad
out right now the media have declared
that all of trumps tweet types are the
last that every single tweet that Trump
issues is the last kind of tweet all of
them are racist all of them are bigoted
all of them are sexist - all of them are
homophobic and so this particular tweet
in which is ripping into a specific
Congress person for a specific Congress
person's failing and that person's
district that is now considered racist
and so the media lose it and they call
all of this racist we'll see that in a
second well President Trump then comes
back for round 2 he was gone I don't
know what was going on I don't know why
the president didn't have a golf game
why he didn't have any shark week to
watch or anything but the president just
kept coming back to Twitter to bang on
this drum over and over and over again
there's a difference between between
useless and bad and racist and the media
doesn't make any of those distinctions
for President Trump
anything that drops out of his mouth
they immediately determined to be racist
even what he is saying is is kind of
true it's kind of true here's the thing
Elijah Cummings has been a
congressperson in Baltimore for decades
at this point Baltimore has been a
terribly governed city for decades now
all of that is certainly not on Elijah
Cummings he is a Congress person he's a
federal Congress person it is not his
job to govern the city of Baltimore it's
generally the job of Congress people
with regards to their local areas to
bring home the bacon
cummings actually has done the problems
in baltimore our locally our local
government related they've had three
mayor's in like four years all of them
ousted for one form of corruption or
another with that said the fact that
President Trump is ripping on Cummings
and the Democrats with regard to
Baltimore he's on fairly solid ground
there Baltimore is not a well-run city
and if you don't believe me all you have
to do is watch one of the greatest shows
in TV history the wire when HBO said it
not racist when Trump says it all of a
sudden racist it's more of that in just
in one second first let's talk about
keeping your home safe and secure so
listen there are a lot of folks out
there who are not fans of the show not
fans of mine and that means that I am
very very focused on ensuring that my
home is safe and secure on a regular
basis and that's why I use ring because
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protects millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone I love ring it is great I mean not
only is it true that when somebody rings
the doorbell I can see who they are
I can also sound an alarm I can make
sure that my property is protected at
all times if I'm 3,000 miles away I
still know exactly what's going on at my
house the same thing is true for
everyone who uses ring as a subscriber
we had a special offer on a ring welcome
kit it's available right now at ring.com
slash but again that's ring.com slash
patent the kit includes a video doorbell
and a chime Pro which is just what you
need to start building a ring of
security around your home today go to
ring.com slash pen again that is
ring.com slash Ben go check them out
right now ring at comm slash Ben ok so
president Trump doesn't stop there he
starts getting hit and that means it's
time to Double Down it's time to double
it down let's do this thing so President
Trump then continues along these lines
he says Elijah Cummings spends all of
his time trying to hurt innocent people
through oversight he does nothing for
his very poor very dangerous and very
badly run district take a look hashtag
black for Trump 2020 and then he starts
tweeting out videos from a reporter who
was being quoted that morning on Fox &
Friends
named Kim kimberleigh classic he tweeted
out rep Cummings why don't you focus on
your districts picture of just garbage
strewn streets in Baltimore and then
continues along these lines right
there's video
and it shows people walking through
actual garbage strewn homes in Baltimore
in this way Baltimore is very much like
other failed Democratic cities like
Detroit there are large swaths of
abandoned houses they're drug houses
there are houses that are following
apart where people are still living in
squalor it really is pretty terrible it
really is pretty terrible and then
president from continues with round
three so this continues and then
president Trump just continued says
someone please explain to Nancy Pelosi
so Pelosi called Trump a racist now and
Trump says someone please explain to
Nancy Pelosi who has recently called
racist by those in her own party that
there is nothing wrong with bringing out
the very obvious fact that congressman
Elijah Cummings has done a very poor job
for his district in the city of
Baltimore just take a look the facts
speak far louder than the words the
Democrats always play the race card when
in fact they've done so little for our
nation's great african-american people
now lowest unemployment in US history
and only getting better Elijah Cummings
has failed badly hey he's not saying
anything that's untrue here guys he
really is not okay you may think that
it's racist just cuz he is talking about
a largely black city with a black
Congress person but he would say this
about white people he would and he has
in the past as I will show you this is
really about President Trump pick the
guy he didn't like decide to rip on him
said something true about that guy said
something true about his city and then
people reacted by saying well just
because he's black you're attacking him
no he's attacking him cuz he doesn't
like him and Elijah Cummings happens to
be black and his City happens to be an
incredibly poorly run City or people
have been suffering for decades from the
effect of terrible terrible governance
this is undeniable gate is undeniable
that Baltimore is a badly run city and
that Baltimore suffers from
extraordinarily high levels of crime and
excited suffers from significant poverty
now it's pocketed poverty so you're
seeing people quote statistics saying
well the average income in Baltimore is
like fifty eight thousand dollars yes
that is true that is also including a
lot of the rebuilt areas that are
government areas if you're talking about
the worst precincts of Baltimore which
is what people think of when they think
of Baltimore those places are truly
horrific really really bad again it's
not as though this has had no media
coverage as we'll get to now president
from continuing she says speaking of
failing badly okay here's an example of
President Trump ripping on a white lady
who happens to live in a white district
that also happens to be turning into a
hellhole right president from
speaking of failing badly has anyone
seen what is happening to Nancy Pelosi's
district in San Francisco it's not even
recognizable lately something must be
done before it is too late the devil
should stop wasting time on the
witch-hunt hoax and start focusing on
our country now again as I say do I
think the President Trump is actually
proposing a policy for San Francisco or
Baltimore no I think that he is mouthing
off because this is what President Trump
does but again there's the difference
between Trump mouthing off and Trump
being useful and from being a racist not
all the same thing as we will see there
are many folks on the Democratic side of
the aisle who have said the same sorts
of things about Baltimore and even have
said the same sorts of things about
Elijah Cummings and nobody has called
them racist the reason being because
they're not Trump the immediate
assumption is that whatever Trump says
is the assumption from the left whatever
Trump says is in effect of his inherent
racism and I'm sorry but that's just not
true
what do you think is a better
explanation for president Trump's
behavior here that he hates black folks
or that he hates Elijah Cummings and is
mouthing off about Elijah Cummings and
people he hates he bashes I mean I think
there's a pretty obvious answer and if
you're not stretching for it people are
there's an exchange between Chris
Wallace and Mick Mulvaney and last week
I praised Chris Wallace when he was
talking with Stephen Colbert about the
mullet hearings but I thought that Chris
Wallace handled it completely wrong with
Mulvaney Mulvaney said you're reading
between the lines and Chris Wallace said
no I'm just reading the lines no you're
not I mean if you're attributing racism
to these comments as we will see in any
context it is impossible to understand
from behavior outside of the context of
who President Trump is and the kind of
stuff that he does and we see this
fairly routinely I remember back during
the campaign there was this big blow-up
over president Trump supposedly mocking
a disabled reporter he was going after a
reporter for the New York Times and he
made some hand motions that looked as
though he was mocking the reporters
disability and he kind of made some
weird noises with his mouth and
everybody immediately including me
immediately jumped to the conclusion
that the president was at that point
ripping into him because of his
disability and it was ugly and it was
not pretty and then there was a video
that came out and it was a compilation
of President Trump making fun of people
and as it turns out he does that weird
voice in the weird hand motions whatever
he's making fun of somebody that he
doesn't like or at least many times and
yet that myth has sort of persisted
about
the fact is Trump's a jerk okay no else
to put this he's a jerk but being a jerk
and being a racist are not necessarily
the same thing saying a jerky thing and
saying a racist thing are certainly not
the same thing and saying a true thing
and saying a racist thing are not the
same thing either his the President
Trump then continues on this doubling
down on the double down
he says Elijah Cummings has had his
chance to address it crime and
conditions in Baltimore for decades he
hasn't gotten it done quoting Pete
hagseth from Fox & Friends and then
Trump says how can he get it done when
he just wants to use his Oversight
Committee to hurt innocent people and
divide our country again this is the
part where I say Trump is not being
sincere
so you're seeing some Trump defenders
today go well no he actually cares about
what's happening in Baltimore he's just
trying to raise one no he's not he's not
from was pissed about how he's handling
the Oversight Committee from this ticket
how he's handling them all our
investigation he's ticked it how he's
handling the Border Patrol stuff and so
he's ripping on him
there's no broader explanation there is
no 3d upside down underwater Hungry
Hungry Hippos happening here this is
very simple President Trump doesn't like
Cummings he used the brick bat closest
at hand the brick bat was that Baltimore
is a horribly run city with a lot of
people living in squalor and he smacked
Cummings with it that's it there is no
giant race baiting technique for 2020
there that's the left to play that's
what they're saying there is no
president Trump is just gaming this
whole thing out and he really cares
about what's happening in Baltimore
that's the rights play no that's not
true either this is President Trump
doing what he always does mouthing off
on Twitter again as it will say on his
epitaph President Trump
45th President of the United States he
sent a lot of bleep end of story and
then President Trump says another true
thing he says there's nothing racist in
stating plainly what most people already
know that Elijah Cummings has done a
terrible job for the people of his
district and a Baltimore itself Dennis
always play the race card when they are
unable to win with facts shame again I
can't argue with this okay logic
Cummings has been a congressperson for a
failing district for decades on end and
then President Trump of course turns it
up to 11 because if the spinal tap if
the spinal tap speaker only goes up to
10 he's got to find the 11 he says if
racist Elijah Cummings okay came ad
nowhere but focus more on his energy on
helping the good people of his district
in Baltimore itself perhaps progress
could be made in fixing the mess that
has helped to create over many years of
incompetent leadership his radical
oversight is joke
keeps going back to this oversight stuff
he keeps going back to the which again
demonstrates he doesn't care about
what's actually happening in Baltimore
so long as he can use it to slam
Cummings now again the slam can be
accurate the tweets can be silly all of
this can be true at once many things can
be true at once you experience it in
your daily life you don't have to be
into President Trump is just trying to
raise awareness of a serious urban issue
that has plagued this country then
where's the plan then where's the plan
if you wanted to make this an issue
which by the way I think Republicans
should make an issue I think Republicans
should make failed city governance by
Democrats a massive issue when
Republicans run cities like New York
City they get cleaned up when Democrats
run cities like Los Angeles they turn
into bleep holes okay I live here I know
okay then Republicans should make that a
point of governing they should make that
a point of campaigning that's not what
Trump is doing here then he says under
the Trump administration he repeats
african-american unemployment is the
lowest best in the history of the United
States no president has come close to
doing this before I also created
successful Opportunity Zones waiting for
Nancy and Elijah to say Thank You mr.
president again this kind of personal
petty kind of stuff why should a Nancy
and Elijah say Thank You mr. president
how about you just did what you were
supposed to do for the country right
isn't that your job okay then we finally
get to the Democratic response now
Democratic response is exactly what you
would think instead of them saying you
know mr. president I don't see that you
have a plan for the inner cities I don't
think you care about that I think you
just don't like Elijah Cummings instead
they immediately that that's a
reasonable critique instead what they
jumped to is a racist racist brutal
racist okay there's only one problem
there's nothing that he said that is
racist just because it Elijah Cummings
is black does not mean that he was
criticizing Elijah Cummings because
Elijah Cummings is black if it Elijah
Cummings were not the head of the
Oversight Committee what Donald Trump be
going after him I highly doubt it
if Baltimore were largely white would
president Trump be going after it I
think the answer is yes since he just
went after San Francisco in that tweet
thread president Trump as we will see
has gone after other white areas trying
to turn everything into a referendum on
racism that's where it's out so you know
I say that Trump is playing the politics
of convenience when he attacks Cummings
over Baltimore he doesn't like Cummings
therefore he says stuff about Baltimore
Democrats claim racism not because what
Trump is doing here is actually racist
they're doing this because what they
hope to run on in 2020 is again Trump is
an evil terrible very bad racist drive
out the black vote in the same way that
Barack Obama did in 2012 hope to win a
massive victory in Ohio Pennsylvania
Wisconsin Michigan by turning out
particularly minority voters in heavily
urban areas right that's what they did
in 2012 they're hoping to do it again in
2020 it is very obvious what is going on
here and we'll get some more of that in
just one second first let's talk about
how to make your business better well
sometimes this involves hiring new
people sometimes it involves replacing
people who are insufficient at their
jobs
not that we've done that ever at daily
wire but hye-rin used to be hard not
anymore now there is zip recruiter come
when someone makes a mistake here on the
bench Shapiro show they know they're on
the hot seat because zipper car is
waiting in the wings like the Grim
Reaper of jobs waiting to replace them
zip recruiter calm slash at daily wire
you can make our business more efficient
you don't have to threaten your own
employees the way that I just did
instead you can just say let's hire some
new people go to zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire zip recruiter sends
your job posting to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlights
the top candidates so you're never gonna
miss a great match zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruit calm slash at Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash at daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire and go check them out right now
okay so Elijah Cummings fires back he
says mr. president I go home to my
district daily right because you live in
Washington DC so it's like not that far
commute does each morning I wake up and
I go and I fight for my neighbors it is
my constitutional duty to conduct
oversight of the executive branch but it
is my moral duty to fight for my
constituents
just yesterday I held a hearing on the
skyrocketing prices of prescription
drugs and the financial hardships that
our families across the nation and in
Baltimore are facing
mr. president we can address this
together two years ago I went to the
White House to ask you to endorse my
bill
to let the government negotiate directly
for lower drug prices you told me then
that you supported the legislation and
that you would work with me to make it
happen I took you at your word and that
is the okay so that that response by
Cummings is not bad
right coming is actually responding
appropriately but that's not how the
Democrats responded okay so Cummings
responds in responsible fashion he says
listen I'm doing my job you may not like
how I do my job but that isn't even my
job that is how a mature person responds
I mean Cummings I got to tell you I
think that Cummings has actually handled
himself in many cases on the Oversight
Committee with a lot more decency than
other Democrats have I mean there have
been situations where Cummings has
actually stepped into the fray and stop
people from attacking for example marsh
meadows with whom he has friends so I'm
not gonna smack Cummings fort for that
response I think that that response is
fine I am gonna smack the media in the
media are a joke and so are a lot of
these other politicians so Victor
Blackwell on CNN immediately gets very
cheerful about this whole thing he rips
on President Trump he suggests that this
is all just another incident of
president Trump's deep abiding of racism
seen the president invoke infestation to
criticize lawmakers before you see a
pattern here
Donald Trump has tweeted more than
43,000 times he's insulted thousands of
people many different types of people
but when he tweets about infestation
it's about black and brown people the
president says about congressman
Cummings district that no human would
want to live there you know who did mr.
president I did people get up and go to
work there they care for their families
there they love their children who
pledge allegiance to the flag just like
people who live in districts of
congressmen who support you sir they are
Americans too okay this is deliberate
miss Reid deliberate mystery to what
Trump is saying obviously okay so he
makes a couple of points here one is
that Trump says no human being would
want to live there he's not saying that
the people who live there are not human
beings of course he is saying why would
you want to live in a district that is
suffering so much they don't deserve
what they're getting that's a deliberate
miss Reid if I say that nobody wants to
live in squalor nobody wants to live in
a rat-infested area nobody wants to live
in bad living conditions that no human
being wants to live there I'm not saying
the people who live there aren't human
beings I'm saying that why would anyone
not want better conditions there why
wouldn't people want BETT I mean that's
that's what he is saying right and when
they talk about infestation okay let's
be very clear
president Trump has used infestation so
he's trying to suggest that infestation
only means black and brown people Trump
has not once referred to black or brown
people as an infestation not once he is
referred to in every tweet I've read all
the squeeze he's talking about he's
talking he is specifically said
crime-infested or rat infested he's
talked about ms-13 those are the only
folks he's ever talked about as an
infestation and ms-13 are an infestation
ms-13 are a terrorist group so when he
says he's only talking about black and
brown people black and brown areas he's
specifically talking about rat in fact
he used the words rat infested okay and
he was using that specifically reacting
to a segment on Fox & Friends that was
dealing with rat infestation in
Baltimore
so again you take President Trump out of
context and read him in the worst
possible light you're gonna come up with
the worst possible solution of course
but when you actually read it in the
context in which was meant he watches a
Fox and Friends segment about Elijah
Cummings and then that segment talks
about rat infestation in Baltimore and
then he tweets about Elijah Cummings and
rat infestation in Baltimore it's hard
for me to go to this is obviously him
being a racist and talking about
infestation because he hates black
people is it again that is that's
deliberately missing the story but
that's what the media do these days so
the mayor of Baltimore jumped in also
the mayor of Baltimore you want to talk
about people who have not done their
jobs the mayor of Baltimore would be the
guy right it'll add your Cummings has
basically done his job to the extent
that he's brought money back to his
district that's what federal Congress
people do they bring the pork home but
the local governance in Baltimore has
been a bleep show since forever going
all the way back to the days of the wire
and long before the mayor Bernard see
young Jesse Jack Young tweeted out it's
completely unacceptable for the
political leader of our country to
denigrate a vibrant American city like
Baltimore and to viciously attack US
representative Elijah Cummings a patriot
and a hero
hey listen again I don't think that it's
worthwhile for the president to
denigrate Baltimore I think that that's
a foolish move but what he is saying
about Baltimore being a bad place to
live for a lot of the people living
there is a obviously true it is
obviously true and it is not racist to
point that out and maybe foolish and
maybe counterproductive it may not be
worthwhile but it is not racist but
according to the MSNBC panel of course
is racism just pure simple obvious
racism there's a lot of talk about how
this is all part of a grand strategy by
the President and
it's really this brilliant diabolical
analogy we are seen to accept the
premise that it's actually useful for
him politically to rile up these racial
tensions to use white identity politics
he has certainly used them for a long
time now
ever since he announced he was running
for president it's not actually clear
that this was going to work especially
in this is just to Donald Trump is he's
just an old racist and this is how he
talks about people this is what he
thinks about people this is not a Grinch
strategy he is not playing four or five
six dimensional chess he's just an old
racist who uses social media those
Republican strategists are endorsing the
strategy that's just nonsense okay first
of all Republican strategists are
generally not endorsing Trump's tweets I
have yet to meet a Republican strategist
in a high position who thinks from
sweets are actually good behind closed
doors with that said is Trump a vicious
old racist just tweeting no he's just a
petty person who is tweeting that is a
better read on President Trump didn't
stop the Democrats right Elizabeth
Warren comes down she says it's racist
it's racist she tweeted out Donald
Trump's tweets are ugly and racist yes I
know you're running for president
Elizabeth I know you are I know senator
Warren you're running for president that
doesn't mean what you're saying is true
she does they're purposefully designed
to turn us against one another we cannot
let that happen instead we must follow
my friend Elijah Cummings example and
keep doing the work for the American
people and then Bernie jumps in does the
same thing what's really going on
representative Cummings has been busy
revealing the failures of the Trump
administration and exposing the greed of
Trump's friends in the pharmaceutical
industry and our racist president
doesn't like it again apparently it is
racist to criticize Baltimore according
to Bernie Sanders and now as it turns
out a few people historically have
criticized Baltimore a few people like
for example Bernie Sanders so let's take
Bernie circa 2015 so this would be clip
20 for Bernie circa 2014 and 2015
talking about Baltimore is this racist
anyone who took the walk that we talked
we took around this neighborhood would
not think you're in a wealthy nation you
would think that you were in a
third-world country but today what we're
talking about is a community in which
half of the people don't have jobs we're
talking about a community in which there
are hundreds of buildings that are
uninhabitable we're talking about a
community where kids are on
able to go to schools that are decent oh
wow
well I mean what a racist what an
obvious racist okay so meanwhile the
media of course continue along this path
so the CNN has a long report today all
about people reacting to President Trump
it's title
Baltimore stands up for its city after
Trump tweets no human being would want
to live there and then they say the
president's tirade was directed at House
Oversight Committee Chairman Elijah
Cummings who represents Maryland's
seventh congressional district in the
house and recently limb bastard
conditions of the border Trump's attack
against Cummings was the latest verbal
assault against a minority member of
Congress who is a frequent critic of the
president okay again it's the media who
keeps saying that he only does this to
minority members of Congress he has made
fun he called Adam Schiff a pencil-neck
hey like really he does this routinely
like a lot
he has nicknames for everyone he doesn't
like okay so everybody reacts to all of
this and they react by suggesting that
the president is acting racist in his
criticism of Baltimore is racist
the Baltimore Sun's editorial board
published a response highlighting
aspects of the city they felt the
president left out the beauty of Inner
Harbor the history of Fort McHenry the
prominence of Johns Hopkins Hospital the
National dependency on the Social
Security Administration which has housed
in Baltimore and it surely wasn't the
economic standing of a district where
the median income is actually above the
national average the board wrote better
to have some verb in living in your
neighborhood than to be one so Trump is
a rap right the idea is that Trump is a
rat and there are no rats in Baltimore
just like in americantale there are no
rats in America no cats in America in
any case the here's the reality there
are some nice areas of Baltimore and
there are a lot of places that are not
so nice and every single human being
with a functioning prefrontal cortex and
at least one functional retina
understands this everyone so let's start
from the beginning what launched this
whole thing what launched this from
president Trump Kimberly Classic
reporter from Baltimore appearing on FOX
Business at 6:00 on Fox and Friends at
6:15 a.m. Eastern Time to talk about
Baltimore and talk about rodent
infestations well play you exactly what
led off this entire tirade in just one
second and then we'll go back into the
history of Baltimore like a year and
what people were saying about Baltimore
before Trump here's the rule Trump says
something it becomes automatically wrong
but what if let me just put this out
there
what if what he said is obviously true
he's just a bore what if that's the case
I mean I know mind blown
but what if that's the actual reality
I'll get to that in just one second
first you know I've always wanted to
know more about my genetic backgrounds
I'm always looking for more information
on myself more information on my health
more information how I can live a better
life and having more information more
data is one of the ways that I can
improve my behavior going forward well
with 23andme health and ancestry service
you can learn how your genes can affect
your health it's a lot to take in but
once you know more you can take action
now to stay healthy better to know than
not to know there's a whole world of
genes just waiting to meet you in 125
plus personalized genetic reports on
your health traits and more the right
personal health plan starts with the
right data your health reports can give
you insights about your DNA so you can
build the health plan that is that is as
unique to you as you are so one of the
things that's really cool is that it
tells you for example how you react to
caffeine so I'm somebody who thought
that I had to take more caffeine than I
did in order to keep myself kind of up
for the show for example I have more
coffee than necessary well after I took
the 23andme ancestry report and said
well that's not how you react to
caffeine I've been drinking less
caffeine it's the same that's great to
know
because it means I'm not having to take
as much you can understand your genetic
predispositions to health conditions
like type 2 diabetes or inherited high
cholesterol all these can help change
your behavior 23andme reports do not
diagnose disease or describe overall
likelihood of developing any disease
23andme test select genetic variants
only visit 23andme comm slash apparel
for important tests information order
your health and ancestry kit at 23andme
comm slash capiro you can meet your
genes in 125 plus personalized genetic
reports that's the number two three-and
me comm / f arrow / Shapiro and by the
way you can also find out if you're more
Native American than Elizabeth Warren
I'm apparently the only person in
America who is not go to 23andme comm /
0 to 3 and me.com slash Shapiro ok so
what led this whole thing off Kimberley
classic appears 6:15 a.m. Eastern Time
and the president doesn't like sleeping
apparently which is wonderful and she
starts talking about Baltimore this is
what led all of this off so what did you
find was going on in Cummings district
you know there is a crisis at the border
but there's also a crisis in Baltimore
and I don't think many people realize
this but congressman Cummings it
represents the most dangerous district
in America
there's abandoned row homes too filled
with trash homeless addicts empty
needles that they abused and it's really
right next door so it's attracting
rodents cockroaches you name it but you
know to have congressman cummings talk
about the situation at the border is
just it's laughable because the
condition was in its own district and a
lot of people said he hasn't even been
there in a while are atrocious and and
not to mention those that live there I
doesn't find any one okay so so that was
the recite meant that let all this off
okay then
Kimberly classic tweeted out a bunch of
these videos and so she tweeted out a
picture of the trash that more trash
more concerned residents people live in
the home with the silver van this is
representative Cummings his district
this has nothing to do with race but us
all pray the city removes the trash and
installs cameras to catch the
individuals dumping on the property and
then she tweeted more about this and
then she tweeted out a video in which
she showed the squalor that a lot of
folks are living in in Baltimore it over
and over and over again everybody knows
this everybody understands that
Baltimore specifically many areas of
Baltimore are not places that you want
to live there residents of Baltimore who
are angry at Cummings who are angry at
the government for not doing what they
are supposed to do are we supposed to
blind ourselves so there are we supposed
to pretend that Baltimore is wonderful
that it's a that's a great place to live
for the bulk of residents who lived
there is that just something we're
supposed to go along with again you can
go along with the median average income
routine but you are including in that
routine all the people who get paid to
teach Johns Hopkins median does not
actually describe the conditions of
people who are living at the lower end
the same people who are declaring that
America is bifurcated between rich and
poor are ignoring exactly that happening
in the city of Baltimore where
democratic governance has been
responsible for it decay and collapse
for decades on end there are certain
areas that are sponsored by the
government like the harbor that have
been beneficiaries of government
largesse but a lot of the folks who are
living there have not benefited from
that largesse I'm not the only one
pointing this out 2018 then the mayor
Catherine Pugh on FOX five
she was ripping the wait for it rat
infestation in Baltimore talking to how
she can smell the rats in Baltimore
Catherine Pugh is black okay so this is
not a race thing Baltimore has problems
obviously now
does this mean that this is what Trump
really wants to talk about the Trump has
a plan for the inner cities or something
like that not true but and this is why I
think people lose their minds over it
but it is also true that just cuz Trump
said it doesn't make it wrong or racist
it doesn't make it a factual or anti
factual or racist
here's Catherine Pugh the mayor of
Baltimore at the time city leaders
identified some of the city's most
violent neighborhoods
what the hell we should just take all
these to target who need to smell the
grants under Baltimore's violence
reduction initiative oh Jesus
just last week we went with mayor Pugh
was she toured in East Baltimore
neighborhood fall towards violence
reduction initiative is about taking
steps to rid communities of the
cornerstones that contribute to crime oh
my god you can smell the dead animals
blocks of dilapidated buildings helped
to hide the addiction that's crippled
this community
okay so again what are we talking about
you've got people coming out of the
woodwork we are Baltimore really do you
live there like in these areas do you
live there is that what you do when you
say we are Baltimore where's your
solidarity can't just be we love
Baltimore and Trump doesn't love
Baltimore that's not what he's saying
he's saying Baltimore deserves better he
may not have a plan for that
he may be lashing out that doesn't
change the underlying fact of what he is
saying it is true hey Fox Fox Baltimore
dot-com
may 17 27 teen quote a project Baltimore
investigation has found five Baltimore
City high schools and one middle school
do not have a single student proficient
in the state tested subjects of math and
English not one we sat down with a teen
who attends one of these schools and has
overcome incredible challenges to find
success davon Warren grew up in West
Baltimore he was three months old when
his father was shot to death before his
18th birthday he would lose two uncles
in a class made all gunned down on the
streets of Baltimore by the way that is
not particularly rare hey this is from
the Baltimore Sun circa April to 2018
quote what's causing Baltimore's
population loss it's no mystery the
city's scary record of 343 homicides in
2017 affirms the city's well-known
reputation as a dangerous place to live
even if 2018 has fewer homicide
it doesn't take a fortune-teller to
predict that this year's homicide rate
will still be high until the city
substantially reduces its homicide and
other crime rates people will continue
to view the city as dangerous and be
reluctant to stay or move here wait wait
wait hold on the Baltimore Sun is saying
that people will be reluctant to stay or
move here like no human being would want
to live here is that what they're saying
is that what they're saying
the city's outrageous property tax of $2
and 24 cents per $100 of a property's
assessed value is more than double its
surrounding jurisdictions Baltimore
County and arendelle the city's
burdensome property tax on homeowners
explains why the city has more renters
than homeowners the city's high income
tax is 3.2 percent the maximum allowed
by law the city's tax message is clear
move here and pay higher taxes people
have figured out how to avoid the city's
taxes and still enjoy the city they live
in surrounding counties and take
reasonably priced ride-sharing services
into the city the city's public school
system is a disaster
again this is Baltimore Sun last year
last year it's a more of this in just
one second first nowadays there are a
lot of different types of cars on the
road there's no way that the local auto
parts store can carry everything that
you need so why wait in line to find the
right part that's probably overpriced
when you can do it all with the
convenience of Rock Auto rockauto.com
it's a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years go
to rockauto.com shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet whether
it's for your classic or daily driver
get everything you need in a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the Rock auto comm catalog is unique
it's easy to investigate and navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and then you can choose the
brands specifications and prices that
you're looking for best of all the
prices at rockauto.com
are always reliably low the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much
money for the same parts they've got
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car is gonna need
Rock Auto calm head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck
don't waste time or money and then write
Shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know that we say that
helps us it also helps them rock Auto
comm go check them out right now if
you're looking for a part for your car
all right we're getting it get into more
of this again not everything that Trump
says is racist and just because from
said it doesn't make it racist
obviously
get to more of that more on the
illustrious recent history of Baltimore
which apparently is a wonderful thriving
area specifically cuz from said it isn't
I mean the Trump is like he I swear he
treats the media and the Democrats the
same way that I sometimes treat my son
when he won't eat and when my son won't
eat I'll say don't eat my don't eat my
food don't do it don't eat my footin and
of course he eats the food trims like
Baltimore bad place bad badly govern
place and Democrats like it's the best
it's the best place like it no no it
isn't I'm sorry it's not like we can
come up with solutions we can try and
work this out but it's not we have to
start from fact okay first you need to
go over to Daley wire.com and subscribe
$9.99 a month ninety-nine bucks a year
the real reason you should subscribe
aside from getting all the goodies the
additional two hours of me every single
day the ability to be in the mail bag
all sorts of wonders
you got our Sunday special on Saturday
the real reason is because there are
folks on the left you spend every single
day I know it's the it's ridiculous they
spend every single day listening to
every moment of the show trying to clip
it out of context and then go after our
advertisers trying to go after places
that we are platformed trying to get rid
of us because this is what members of
these and serious left do the way you
protect that the way that you prevent
that from happening
ensuring that we can continue to bring
us bring you the content that you want
as you subscribe and you become part of
the team it's something that I really
appreciate on a personal level I know
everybody at the company appreciates it
you want to make sure our producers keep
getting paid that's the way to do it you
go over to daily wire comm and subscribe
it right now for 99 bucks a year you get
this the very greatest and beverage
vessels he left his tears hot or cold
tumbler replenishing daily go check it
out right now we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so again the reaction of the media has
been President Trump can't attack
Baltimore that's racist
he can't say that Baltimore is a bad
place to live that's racist
he can't say that certain parts of the
city are rat infested and they've got
it's been a horribly governed city
that's racist really because until five
minutes ago everybody agree about this
hey David plush a flashier plush a
writing for the Baltimore Sun as you say
wrote a piece in April 2018 called
what's causing Baltimore's population
loss
Baltimore's population reached a near
100-year low last year
they say well that would be the high
property taxes the fact that there's
extraordinary levels of crime in the
city quote the city's public school
system is a disaster if anyone thinks a
family would move to the city or stay in
the city because of its public school
system they have another think coming
the city's public school enrollment is
on the decline the city's aged
infrastructure is terrible the city's
random water main breaks spontaneous
sinkholes desperately needed roadwork
means the cash-strapped city faces many
repairs with costs lurking to fix its
dilapidated infrastructure the money to
fund these repairs will either be taken
from other services or city residents
will have to pay higher taxes the mayor
and large time largely part-time City
Council are fiscally irresponsible
they accepted a raise in December the
mayor gets paid 180 grand a year the
city council president 120 grand a year
the City Council VP 77 grand a year and
13 others 69 grandeur plus all have
benefits and all have paid support staff
and they passed a law that entitles
elected officials to receive an
automatic two point five percent raise
if the city budget provides money for a
union employee raises Baltimore's
elections do not change the direction of
the city in the 2016 city general
election the mayor and councilmembers
all promised change but the city is in
the same or worse shape since the
election and that this isn't me writing
this okay this is a writer from
Baltimore Allen and David Platt sir last
year in the Baltimore Sun here also
Baltimore Sun September 25th 2018 Luke
Broadwater and Ian Duncan quote
neighborhoods are crying out Baltimore
has highest homicide rate of us big
cities Baltimore had the worst homicide
rate among the nation's 50 largest
cities last year the second highest
violent crime rate overall according to
new data from the FBI this is the place
that is being called utopia today
because President Trump said it's a bad
place to live
grim news was the latest reminder of the
sustained cycle of violence that has
gripped the city since 2015 when the
annual number of homicides soared above
300 for three consecutive years after
the unrest that followed Freddie Gray's
death from injuries suffered in police
custody just last year PBS aired in an
actual documentary it was called wrath
film about Baltimore talking about how
the city was infested by rats the
Baltimore Sun reported quote rat film a
documentary that takes the decades-long
fight waged against Baltimore's rat
population and uses it as a lens through
which to look at how the city has
addressed myriad social issues over the
decades airs tonight on PBS again it was
called rat film but if president says
it's rat infested then he means black
people according to the left in 2016 the
Baltimore Sun ran an op-ed the day after
President Trump was declared the winner
of the 2016 election talking about how
Baltimore should be declared a disaster
and rebuilt from the ground up and yet
now we are supposed to believe obviously
that Baltimore is a wonderful city
because President Trump has declared it
not so because presidents from declared
that Baltimore is in fact a bad place to
live and reasonable people don't want to
live there because of that Baltimore is
now great
hey Baltimore has been horribly governed
for years we all remember the Freddie
gray riots in 2015 we all remember this
Baltimore burned and that was mainly
black folks burning down areas in which
lots of black folks lived there was a
black City Council a black police chief
of majority black police force and and a
black mayor and everybody was talking
about white privilege kids ridiculous
it's a horribly governed City how
horribly governed is the city it's so
horribly govern than in the middle of
those riots over the death of Freddie
gray
who allegedly was was picked up by the
police on some crime after he tried to
run and then put in the back of the van
and then he wasn't properly handcuffed
and so he was like jostled in the back
of the van there were accusations the
police killed him those accusations were
never proved instead what it seems that
he sort of fell over and broke his neck
is a tragic terrible story riots ensued
because supposedly the police are
viciously and brutally racist despite
the fact that again the police force the
police chief was black and majority of
the city's police force is black and
despite
the mayor of Baltimore at the time
Stephanie rawlings-blake held a press
conference in which she specifically
suggested that she was going to give
rioters room to riot and you're gonna
tell me this is a well governed city
made it very clear that I worked with
the police and instructed them to do
everything that they could to make sure
that the protesters were able to
exercise their right to free speech it's
a very delicate balancing act because
while we try to make sure that they were
protected from the cars and the other
you know things that were going on we
also gave those who wished to destroy
space to do that as well and we worked
very hard to to keep that balance and
and to put ourselves in the best
position to de-escalate and Trump
doesn't have solutions and trumpet
didn't provide solutions and Trump isn't
talking about solutions but his
diagnosis of the problem is not
incorrect obviously you had the mayor of
the city talking about letting rioters
riot hey she's the mayor
it's a horribly governed city it's been
horribly governed for decades again HBO
had a very long running show called The
Wire many consider it the best show in
TV history specifically about the
corruption and inability of anybody to
do anything about how horrible Baltimore
is it's a bad place to live everyone
knows this just because Trump said it
doesn't make it untrue you know who used
to say this openly you know in fact
there is a person in the media obviously
a vicious racist obviously a terrible
vicious racist who used to ask Elijah
Cummings directly whether this was a
democratic failure and whether Democrats
had failed to govern this place properly
after all this is Cummings district now
I've been told that if you say that
Elijah Cummings has done a bad job for
Baltimore this means you're a racist so
Chris Cuomo come on down this is Chris
Cuomo circuit's 2015 and maybe people
have forgot about this but here's Chris
Cuomo saying it Baltimore has been run
by Democrats and recently
african-american Democrats for a really
long time it's not really about
Republicans I mean the Democrats you've
had your people in their room
congressman Cummings I mean you know you
guys are as responsible for what has and
hasn't been
done as anybody else isn't that fair
Chris come on Chris you know it's not
about personalities is about policy and
you know and I know that a lot of the
policies coming down from Washington
coming down for the state actually - but
coming from Washington are not
necessarily kind to urban areas
particularly yeah lately okay so it's
obviously because of the the urban
problems coming down from the federal
government the time led by Barack Obama
and his Attorney General who at the time
was was what's what's-her-face
not-not-not Eric Holder who is the who's
the Loretta Lynch thank you you know
that again this is apparently Chris
Cuomo racist go back to 2015 how dare he
question Elijah Cummings on his own
governance unbelievable okay now how
about president Trump's infested
language so we heard as we say earlier
the president Trump used the language of
infested and I pointed out then whenever
he says infested he is talking about
crime infested there is always some sort
of noun that proceeds infested right rat
infested crime-infested drug infested
and I've said that he doesn't only say
this about black areas am i wrong room
at well it turns out as per our usual
arrangement I am correct hey Liam stack
writing for The New York Times August
3rd 2017 New Hampshire politicians
criticized President Trump after a
transcript of a phone call with the
President of Mexico published on
Thursday showed he called the state a
quote drug infested dead now there is
there are very few whiter states in
America the New Hampshire New Hampshire
is incredibly white their mark came
during his comments on the drug trade
criminal gangs and how he said they
affected the state according to a
transcript of the January 27th call
published by The Washington Post the
drug lords in Mexico are knocking the
hell out of our country Trump told
President Enrique Pena Nieto of Mexico
quote they're sending drugs to Chicago
Los Angeles in New York up in New
Hampshire I won New Hampshire because
New Hampshire is a drug infested den is
coming from the southern border this of
course led a lot of people to criticize
him but not call him racist right
Governor Chris Sununu was a Republicans
and the president is wrong is
disappointing his mischaracterization of
this epidemic ignores the great things
this state has to offer the New
Hampshire Democratic Party tweeted out a
picture of one area of New Hampshire
pretty said how about this Donald
Trump's this seemed like a drug-infested
den but I guess it's racist when he been
told he only says infested about black
and brown people not about you know the
whitest area in the United States New
Hampshire so obviously that is untrue
all of this is very cynical now Trump
makes his own bed to a certain extent
not being called racist being called
racist that's just something Democrats
do with everyone they did with Mitt
Romney they did it with John McCain they
did it with George W Bush they do it
with everyone everyone on the right is
called the racist which is why so many
people on the right are very hesitant to
go along with left's definition of
racism because the left's definition of
racism is basically I disagree with you
but in this particular case he didn't
say anything racist in this particular
case he did not say anything racist and
people on the Left are jumping on this
is racist because this is part of the
broader overarching narrative that Trump
is a racist in the Republican Party is a
racist and if you vote for Trump than
you're racist they tried this in 2016 it
didn't win them Oh hiyo Pennsylvania
Michigan or Wisconsin so we'll see how
it works out again it's a bold move
cotton continuing to suggest that
everyone who is thinking about voting
for Trump is inherently a racist and
that everything Trump says is racist
it's so funny all Democrats had to do is
not be crazy that's all they had to do
and again I say Elijah Cummings his
response to Trump was the correct
response if you are a sane rational
Democrat Cummings his response is the
right one but that's not what they're
doing instead they're sending Al
Sharpton who's an actual racist KL
Sharpton who actually hates Jude a
person who is called Jews diamond
merchants and suggested in the middle of
a of a racial fray that if you wanted to
fight him you pin back your yarmulke and
come on over to his house a person who
is involved with the 1991 Crown Heights
riots that ended with the murder of an
Orthodox Jew named Yankel Rosenbaum al
Sharpton is now being deployed to
Baltimore where hasn't he done a lot of
good in Baltimore al Sharpton hasn't he
done a lot of good for the United States
that racial con artist al Sharpton
Donald Trump by the way ripping into al
Sharpton this is well deserved he says I
must have known I have known al for 25
years went to fights with him and Don
King always got along well again first
of all why are you yes this was a bad
move by you al Sharpton was always a bag
of junk al Sharpton was the person who
was pushing the Tawana Brawley hoax
Trump says he loved Trump he would ask
me for favors often Alize con man a
troublemaker always looking for a score
you only surrounds himself with the best
people does the president he says just
doing his thing must have intimidated
Comcast NBC hates white and cops al
Sharpton is indeed a bag of junk he's a
bad human being he's a very very bad man
Seth Mandel has a piece about Al
Sharpton in the Washington Examiner
talking about the long history of Al
Sharpton just he has been responsible
for for an enormous amount of suffering
al Sharpton ranging from the Tawana
Brawley hoax all the way through the the
Crown Heights riots of 1991 to the to
the Freddie's fashion Mart burning of
1997 1998 all of this is really ugly
stuff and it's worth noting that
Sharpton's returns respectability was
pushed by none other than Barack Obama
who really tried to bring him in house
Barack Obama by the way is sounding off
on all this - as the president obama was
not divisive on racial matters president
of the first the first major statement
on race he made as president of the
united states was to declare that the
cambridge police acted stupidly
interesting and Henry Louis Gates a
Harvard professor who was standing
outside his house without his keys
trying to bang get in wouldn't show them
ID and screaming and Barack Obama
tweeted out I've always been proud of
what this team accomplished during my
administration he's talking about some
145 black members of his administration
who wrote an op-ed over the weekend
talking about from his mean and cruel
his I've always been proud about this
team accomplished during my
administration but more than what we did
I'm proud of how they're continuing to
fight for an America that's better
Barack Obama was a racially polarizing
president he was particularly in a
second term this is true from ever in
everything from Trayvon Martin who could
have been his son to the Baltimore riots
to the Ferguson riots Barack Obama was a
device of racial presidents and now he's
injecting himself back in man if you
think 2019 is ugly wait until we hit
2020 we are a year and a half away from
this election guys if things are this
hot and we're a year and a half away
from the election man are things gonna
get ugly by the time we actually hit
that election but again you know it's
funny though the left is declaring that
this is all part of trumps race-baiting
strategy there's a piece today by a New
York Times columnist named Kevin Cruz a
professor of history at Princeton who's
very good at doing bad history talking
about how President Trump is just like
George Wallace of Alabama you know
except for the whole president
doesn't stand in the doorways of schools
and declare segregation forever he's
exactly the same except for the fact
that Trump doesn't SiC hoses on black
people and dogs on black people exactly
the same as George Wallace but this is
this is where we're going this is where
we are going and it's going to get ugly
don't believe everything you read in the
media again just because Trump said it
doesn't make it untrue doesn't make it
racist he might not like Trump you might
think that he's a liar you might think
he's racist that does not mean that when
he says that Baltimore is a bad place to
live he is wrong he is not and when you
declare everything racist it makes most
Americans think that your definition of
racism is itself over broad and makes
people less likely to listen to you
already time for a quick thing that I
like and then a thing I hate okay thing
that I like today Kevin Williamson has a
new book so Kevin Williamson
you'll recall was hired by the Atlantic
he was a National Review columnist op-ed
guy really terrific writer so Kevin is I
think it's fair to say one of the
world's great misanthropes he hates
humans I have yet to meet a human that
Kevin who actually likes but he is also
a terrific writer maybe maybe the best
American writer on the right he's just
his command of language is fantastic
it's colorful it's creative well he was
hired by the Atlantic because he is all
of these things and then within like
three days jeffrey goldberg was a
spineless pathetic pusillanimous wimp
but and was before he hired Kevin
Williamson
he fired Kevin Williamson at the behest
of some of the people in his company who
said how could we hire Kevin Williamson
he's too pro-life
he's scary to me he's scary and he's
bald he's scary and so he was fired
well now kevin has a new book out it's
called the smallest minority independent
thinking in the age of mob politics
basically he craps on everyone which
makes it fairly amusing it he has some
fare he hasn't pretty interesting and
deep takes on what exactly has happened
how folks have caved to a sort of
corporate mentality and the private
sector something that folks on the right
don't think about enough and at the same
time how government has become sort of
the be-all end-all of American life how
the individual has been left behind in
the quest for group solidarity and how
this is not going to lead to anything
good a lot about social media hear a lot
about Twitter the book is called the
smallest minority independent thinking
in the age of mob politics
beware of the f-word there's a lot of it
but it's really color for writing it's
it's it's a quick read if not
necessarily an easy read there's there's
a lot there and Kevin
has yet to meet a person he will not
drop a bomb on and so there's a lot of
that the book is the smallest minority
independent thinking in the age of mob
politics it's a target-rich environment
kevin has a lot of them they'll check it
out the smallest minority okay time for
some things that I hate a first quick
thing I hate remember when we learned
just a few minutes ago they're not
allowed to say infested because if you
say that Baltimore is infested that
means you're talking about black and
brown people allegedly well what about
this article from The Washington Post
today Kushner owns lots of Baltimore
area apartments some are infested with
mice so I guess the rule is you can talk
about infestations in Baltimore so long
as Jared Kushner's company owns
apartment complexes that have mice in
them but you can't talk about the
generalized infestation problem in
Baltimore which by the way was declared
a top ten city for rat infestation by
Orkin this year congratulations
prizes on its way so infestation you can
talk about it
when its Kushner good job guys meanwhile
the the Rashida Talib continues to be
one of the leading lights in the US
House of Representatives
she is supposed to be one of our great
leaders she was on CNN with Jake Tapper
on Sunday and Jake in a very soft way
basically exposed her for what she is
which is a radical anti-semite so she
was talking about Israel and she
suggested a couple of things this is
this was the second clip but to leave is
the limit that I care about most here
Rashidah Talib is asked about the very
often made charge that folks who push
boycott divestment and sanctions from
Israel don't care about human rights
violations going on in other parts of
the world because specifically they
don't like Jews and so Talib has asked
about this tapper says okay so you talk
about boycotting Israel cuz of human
rights violations well why not
Egypt why not Pakistan listen to her
pathetically weak answer we all know
under Netanyahu's regime human rights
violations have gotten worse and we need
to be why don't see why not boycott
Egypt but there right now there is not a
bill or resolution on the floor that is
saying stop boycotting Egypt but you
could of course and I would absolutely
oppose any sort of oppression of freedom
of speech of First Amendment right in
this country it's a slippery slope Jake
she opposes sanctions on Iran she
opposed to sanctions on Venezuela she's
a damn liar and everybody knows it
about the Jews she Tapper says you could
lead this thing yeah no but there's
no movement that which begs the question
why aren't you starting the movement
since you are in favor of the movement
to boycott Israel of course she's a liar
everybody knows that she's a liar but
we're all gonna pretend the bigotry only
exists on one side of the aisle and
we're gonna pretend that stuff that
isn't bigotry is bigotry so that we can
make that claim all right we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right